it is now 503. you know college students
have faced unique challenges we all
really have during the last two years of
coronavirus and may's mental health
awareness month so we're highlighting
the need for resources and for
intervention mary jane belliesa joining
us live at the college of southern
nevada with more on some of the help
that's available so important mary jane
heather absolutely and according to a
2021 mayo health clinic report an
upwards of 44 percent of college
students report symptoms of anxiety and
depression and college students are
working to break the stigma surrounding
mental health college student nyla
marquez says that she's basically
transitioning from online classes to
in-person instruction which proved to be
a challenge for her during the pandemic
citing low motivation and feelings of
loneliness as the main areas of concern
while mark has identified these stresses
early on and knew reaching out for help
is important she knows it's not as easy
for everyone
it sounds kind of corny but it's like
you're not alone there's a reason why
there's mental health awareness month
and why there's different services
available you know it's always best to
try and help yourself first because your
mental health matters more than just
like some assignment that you need to do
or any like job that you need to work
for
marquez says developing a strong support
system is key even if it means reaching
out to your fellow teachers and students
on campus if you're in need of help both
csn and unlv offer caps that's
counseling and psychological services
free of charge for students reporting
live at csn off of
charleston and torrey pines mary jane
ballaza live local now